lisa want to see some good vfx
the folder exploded before it touched it
boom
[Applause]
hello there hello there welcome to
another episode of vfx artist react
today the prequels oh boy what a time
for star wars when george lucas gave it
his one last good hurrah and then got
kind of depressed and sold the franchise
to disney you might be thinking we're
gonna be bashing on these movies because
everyone loves to hate the prequels but
here's the thing the prequels had some
revolutionary visual effects shots and i
want to see whether or not they still
stack up today so let's look at some
shots all right here we go
now this is pod racing this scene got me
so hyped this is a six scene yeah this
looks incredible this looks so good
looks really good like the 3d rendering
here is out of this world is this the
same kid from uh jingle all the way i
don't know i think it's the same kitchen
although i think it's pretty sure it is
i'm willing to bet you ten dollars
that's not jamie it's jamie dude they
did projection mapping for for a lot of
this pod racing scene it was like
literally two guys did 70 of all the
backgrounds for this entire scene wow
and they basically just took a lot of
pictures of you know arches and stuff
like that and they projected it onto 3d
models and that allowed them to have
very realistic looking environments that
you're able to put the camera anywhere
you want to another really cool thing
about the scene is the motion blur this
is a full physically accurate motion
blur render and the reason you can tell
is because the ground is blurred
but the shadows are not blurred you see
the moving and over like the bumps and
stuff like that and they get motion blur
from that motion but the shadows are
technically moving at the same speed as
the camera so there's no directional
motion blur on the shadows whereas
you're getting directional motion blur
on the ground that they're on top of
it's such a great example of people
achieving good looking motion blur in cg
which is very hard to do
dude that shot looks so good the mirage
they had the mirage
the mirage effect is basically the heat
of the ground gets hot enough that it
actually starts kind of acting like a
reflective mirror and such a hard thing
to simulate you just got to be an artist
about even now there's not a shader you
can just turn on for mirage effect that
looks so good that shot dude they spent
a lot of time in the sequence that's for
sure
that is that is a crowd manipulation
shot though you can kind of see it's a
little like odd looking it's the same
people copied and pasted and exactly
let's see if you can find the same
costumes you got uh you got rogue person
with the belt that guy just straight up
got duplicated
whoa i love these crashes whoa that was
i think that's all computer generated
like the way it crumbles yeah it
crumbles the powder exploded before it
touched it wait go back boom
how do you think they did that then do
you think that was an actual filmed
element of an explosion that was tracked
in no i know those look like cg those
are trailers
god that looks so good though those
pieces man how do they go physics looks
so good that's the thing the motion
every everything makes sense it hits
that it starts spinning that way then
hits the ground and starts spinning the
other way that's crazy
okay welcome to the jar jar binks
section oh
[Music]
did you expect us to react violently
against the jar jar binks part of this
episode guess what jar jar binks is
actually pretty well done as far as
visual effects go jar jar binks is kind
of a master class for 1999. this was the
first time you ever had a fully computer
generated character interacting with
real actors having mannerisms they had
motion capture for the first time and
then they had to go and give them a
caribbean accent it's embarrassing
yeah people haven't done a full cg main
character before so like how we're gonna
do this guy well we have a costume why
don't we just replace his head there's
shots of the guy in the costume it's
really strange looking i've never seen
that before he's got like cool shades on
i'm surprised how realistic his arms
kind of look i think they covered up his
eyes the actors didn't look at his eyes
they looked at the mask i think you're
absolutely right can you imagine like
jar jar binks is up here and the actor's
like yeah how are you doing and he's
like why are you looking at his neck
ian mcgregor is doing a good job looking
him in the eyes he's looking a little
high right there
when you have a guy in the costume it's
still human proportions like for example
our forearms are made a certain size so
that we can touch our shoulders
if you want jar jar to have wonky
proportions you can't get that with a
person in a costume they end up just
having the same proportions as a regular
human being and so they did a test
can you tell which one's which no
looking at the proportions of the arms
now those look like real arms this is
digital well like the movement is a much
more cartoony in the second take yep
it does like this jar jar binks is just
a straight up cartoon and it kind of
represents george lucas no longer taking
the world seriously as far as like cg
work goes though it's like so hard to do
especially back in 1999 so you guys
might think that all these effect shots
require millions of dollars and huge
teams of advanced technicians but that's
not always the case look at this
beautiful scene look at those super
intense water simulations of the
waterfall you think those are super
intense water simulations for the
waterfalls you think those took huge
computers many many months to calculate
those incredible waterfalls i have a
feeling that it's not the case but i'm
going to play along yes i think there
are simulations that took hundreds of
hours guess what these are waterfalls
that you could create at home because
all they're doing for these waterfalls
is pouring salt salt salt down
a black screen that's so cool so you're
getting the realistic motion of water
but because it's white it's actually
making it look like it's just like the
really churned up uh foam of a waterfall
that yeah whatever the best kind of
visual effects is when it's creative
negotiations with a lightsaber pair
scene here's a bad idea of a scene
on the big screen in the theater it was
rough look at these zooms
wait are those are those digital zooms
actually in the movie yeah okay watch
this that's a cg pair check it out okay
floating
can you imagine trying to eat nothing
like we'll make it look good later like
all right
it's so much better with that sound
effect i mean look at that distortion
through the actual vase yeah water there
that's that's good some set designer
decided to give everybody like glass
plates and like glass vases and i'm sure
the vfx guy was just like oh my god
they're dealing with green screen too
yeah it's just green screen city in the
back or blue screen whatever it's
probably blue screen look at this and
you're gonna you're having a key that
vase right there yeah that's rough dude
you can see a hint of the blue in the
vase so tough that's tough what a
nightmare are there any more shots of
these two hanging out like maybe in a
field
[Music]
so this is like equivalent to like the
legolas elephant scene from lord of the
rings look at the frolicking in the
field with the giant
tick bugs they're in for a storm that
night that looks cool
dude look at his physics
who's he's standing on that thing
in this fall coming up right here
[Laughter]
wow i do remember thinking that was very
wonky when i saw it for the first time
it's still so wonky it's really really
wonky look at the way it doesn't
backflip off that thing you just like
they just lift them up they rotate the
blue screen element
like he's literally standing on the
front of it as it's rocking around like
a bull they look like they're filled
with blood like giant ticks they do i
guess they just eat a lot of grass all
ford's legs are up front but all of its
weight in the back technically things
just just be like butt scooting across
the field like a dog
oh is this the yoda fight of course it's
the other fight it's when yoda was
fighting saruman and what's funny is
it's very similar to the gandalf fight
too
yeah oh you're right
so far the only thing that is real that
we've seen so far is saruman here his
name is
when this happened in the theaters i was
blown away yeah this was the coolest
moment yeah of the entire movie for me
christopher lee is he's just fighting
the air he's doing a great job of it
what a fantastic actor an interesting
thing to note is that yoda's lightsaber
casts light onto him but christopher
lee's lightsaber doesn't cast any light
onto him the reason you can see it on
yoda is because he's a 3d model and he
has a 3d model lightsaber so they can
cast light from that 3d model lightsaber
onto the 3d model right there yeah you
see that you see it really well there
but they had to be careful because they
can't cast any light on christopher lee
so they have to keep the light really
subtle on yoda so it doesn't stand out
that christopher lee is just standing in
blackness holding a red lightsaber
lightsabers are done usually just by
drawing it on the frame afterwards so
the person's just fighting with a stick
and then you can do something like after
effects or photoshop or whatever you
just draw basically a glowing laser and
the laser is actually just a white strip
with a colored glow on the edges but the
thing is because it's something you just
paint on afterwards there's no lighting
actually affecting the environment
technically the lightsabers be super
bright it's bright white it's blowing
out the camera they should be like
blinding everybody
dude this was my favorite this is such a
good fight darth maul is so sick
favorite of the mall of the mall what a
move what a tactical move this whole
fight oh my god i nearly lost it man
this whole fight is so intense i feel
like the opinion of this movie kind of
like evolves over time people hate it
people love it people hate it again
people love it again whoa whoa whoa did
you see that what look at that you see
the dimming of that lightsaber oh yeah
yeah yeah dude is that a masking issue
is that like a keying issue it's like
what i don't i don't know what's
happening right there really strange man
it must just be a blending thing
you just straight up holding like a toy
lightsaber it looks like you gotta feel
through it you can see through it that's
so weird the the white level is brought
down what if it's just like i think it
is a color thing and they're just
lowering the brightness of it but you
can't lower something that's eight bit
because the data is not there it's been
clipped so you just lower it to like a
gray yeah it's definitely a color
grading
thing look at the key
it clips through oh my god
what you're seeing there on the
background is they filmed them on a blue
screen and you got like individual hairs
and folds of fabric and motion blur and
all that kind of stuff and some guys
sitting there being like screw it
blur it smooth it send it out if you
ever feel bad about your keying just
know that this is a theatrical release
right here now the thing is
no one cared because there's a sick ass
fight scene happening at the penultimate
moment in the movie yeah
no rey
oh and then the movie solo basically
said that darth maul is still alive
nothing like taking hard earned story
points and just
sorry
i'm supposed to just react to visual
effects i'll keep adjusting visual
effects you know i should mention that
one of the reasons we're even reacting
to these prequels right now is because
of the comments that you guys left if
you want us to react to certain vfx
shots that you couldn't figure out how
they're done or you think they're just
mind-blowingly awesome or whatever it is
please leave a comment don't hesitate
all right that's enough
back back to the reacting
so i remember being a big fan of this
whole final this sequence was awesome
yeah i love the sequence and this is all
computer generated nothing in this shot
right here is real the background might
be a model oh bring it down bring it
down boys
this right here oh that's cool this
right here was nuts especially the first
time seeing it in theaters okay this
looks like something out of the newest
trilogy to be honest remember what i
said earlier about the lightsabers
usually being painted on yeah the same
goes for lasers in the movie the lasers
and lightsabers the exact same effect
but this is 100 cg so they're able to
have lights as part of the the lasers
moving through the scene and so for the
first time you see the environment lit
up from the lasers flying through you
see the soldiers getting lit up you see
the bad guys getting lit up you see the
silhouettes changing as lights move
through it and the way the dust and dirt
moves is extremely realistic check that
out check that red light coming through
the crowd there this is included by the
people in the foreground who haven't
been hit by the light yet yeah this is
awesome up to this point in terms of
computer graphics nothing like this had
ever been done because you didn't have
full battlefield scenes like this that
were 100 cg and you didn't have smoke
that was 100 cg you didn't have
atmosphere that's 100 cg so this is the
first time all that came together in a
shot and you're seeing lasers here in a
way that you have never seen lasers
before in cinema it is a bit jarring
going from that awesome laser shot to
this
with a thoughtful yoda did you know that
they didn't build a single clone trooper
helmet for this entire
really
every single helmet was fake the
filmmakers at the time thought okay we
can get away with doing this we don't
have to build that and everyone reacted
and negatively did that because it you
could feel that it wasn't tangible i
mean the reason this stuff looks fake is
just the lighting simulation isn't up to
us yeah shadow from yoda's hair on his
head isn't quite there the hair is just
kind of floating on his head there's
like no shadow
the subsurface scattering on his ears
there's no grunge pass on the reflection
on his chest plate there's a like
fingerprint same for yoda too like he
just kind of seems like a toy here and
the ambient light is very very flat
that's something that i think most
people don't really appreciate has been
developed a lot over the last couple
decades is rendering of light
another thing that they did in these
movies they had these super chromed out
spaceships they wanted to show off all
the really cool reflections
whoa
he wasn't even tracked in oh
look at the background the whole shots
retimed there is retiming artifacts
there look at that right there look at
the right side there that whatever that
little black stick coming out like that
panel is now if you go towards a frame
see how it there's double imaging and
you go forwards frame again and now it's
back to a single image and you go
forwards again double image so i think
what's happening here is the guy falling
is going too slow they need to re-time
it so it hits the ground faster but they
didn't record it in slow motion so what
they're basically doing is creating a
morph for those extra frames that don't
exist but you're getting artifacts
because of that arguably we're just
catching it because i'm being really
scrutinizing
whoa look at that guy
you can see inside of his head so
obviously there's not a human head
inside of that robot it's not a costume
but now he's walking around the scene it
looks pretty good it moves really nicely
do you think that computer generated
c-3po here no i think that's a 3d model
it is not a 3d no no this weight right
you know why because it looks so good do
you know what they did he's a puppet and
there's an actual person attached to the
back of him operating him no really he's
just like i'm doing this but like the
sticks are coming off me and moving the
guy in front of me yeah wow that's smart
that's the way to do it and you can
actually see in the final shot here they
have to do a light wrap around him that
fuzzy like bloomed out highlight around
his shoulder is because there's a person
occluding the background in that shot
that they had to remove
and then add him back into that shot so
actually the whole background is
probably a separately filmed clean plate
what
that's not star wars these guys
have been hard at work oh my god me and
ren have been cranking really hard on us
have you ever wanted to see the boston
dynamics robots turn on the scientists
well that's that's kind of what we did
using motion capture technology fully cg
characters we would love if you guys
went and checked it out on youtube.com
corridor digital we're very proud of it
there's actually a crew video on this
channel that you can check out kind of
detailing all the hard work we put into
it and all the pain we suffered to get
there you guys have any movies or tv
shows that you're like well how do they
do those vfx type up a little comment
also if you are not subscribed to the
corridor crew channel well what the heck
are you waiting for and here's a hint
for what's going to be in our next video
i don't know you'll have to find out